was ist leben was unterscheidet mich und
dich von so etwas hier im alltag
erscheinen uns diese grenze klar und
deutlich eine katze lebt ein auto nicht
wir leben und unser computer nicht aber
lasst uns mal darüber nachdenken was es
eigentlich heißt zu leben und ich warne
euch vor es wird wieder verrückt
ok fangen wir mal ganz einfach an ein
paar übliche eigenschaften von lebewesen
sind zum beispiel dass sie veränderungen
in ihrer umgebung registrieren sich
fortpflanzen können und dass sie einen
stoffwechsel haben
damit wäre das hier schon mal raus aber
was zum beispiel ist feuer feuer hat
einen stoffwechsel es konsumiert
sauerstoff und hinterlässt asche und
rauch es kann sich fortpflanzen und es
reagiert auf seine umwelt oder wir alle
wissen das feuer nicht lebendig ist eine
weitere typische eigenschaft von
lebewesen ist homöostase die fähigkeit
sich selbst aktiv zu regulieren und ein
gleichgewicht aufrecht zu erhalten und
die schließt feuer damit wieder vom
kreis der lebenden aus aber das beispiel
zeigt es ist unglaublich schwierig eine
grenze zu ziehen auf der einen seite
tote materie die nur reagiert und auf
der anderen seite lebendige lebewesen
die agieren können und sich für uns
grundlegend von toten dingen
unterscheiden
eine form die diese grenze weiter
verwischt und wissenschaftlern seit
jahrzehnten kopfzerbrechen bereitet sind
viren viren erfüllen die meisten
eigenschaften von lebewesen können sich
aber nur mit hilfe eines wirts körpers
vermehren und auch die frage ob ein
stoff wechsel stattfindet ist noch nicht
ganz geklärt
viren sind wie kleine maschinen mit ganz
vielen knöpfen und schaltern
wenn die zelle auf einen wirtz körper
trifft werden automatisch prozesse in
gang gesetzt und mit der zeit haben sich
variationen entwickelt die sich auf
unterschiedliche arten und weisen
vermehren
aber nichts anderes sind unsere eigenen
körperzellen doch auch kleine maschinen
die chemikalie aufeinander reagieren
aber wann entsteht dann leben wie viele
zellen ergeben zusammen ein bewusstsein
eine einzelne zelle kann nicht denken
aber millionen davon tun es jetzt gerade
in unserem gehirn ist es nur eine frage
der komplexität
um diesen gedanken zu veranschaulichen
möchte ich euch ein spiel zeigen das
spiel des lebens
es wurde 1970 von mathematiker john
cornwell erfunden und funktioniert recht
einfach man beginnt mit einem gitter das
beliebig groß sein kann
jedes feld kann entweder lebendig oder
tot sein und es gibt nur vier simple
regeln die bestimmen wie sich diese
zellen rundenbasiert verhalten
die vier regeln sind eine tote zelle mit
genau drei lebenden nachbarn wird in der
nächsten runde neu geboren
lebende zellen mit weniger als zwei
lebenden nachbarn sterben in der
nächsten runde eine lebende zelle mit
zwei oder drei lebenden nachbarn bleibt
am leben und die letzte regel lebende
zellen mit mehr als drei lebenden
nachbarn sterben
das mag jetzt auf den ersten blick sehr
willkürlich klingen und nicht viel sinn
und verstand haben
aber was diese regeln mit mustern
anstellen ist einfach faszinierend
schaut euch an
manche konstellationen verschwinden
innerhalb von wenigen runden
andere laufen unendlich lange weiter es
entstehen muster sogar zellen eigene
wesen die sich über die karte bewegen
fans dieses spiels haben unglaublich
viele zellen artige konstrukte gefunden
und sie benannt es gibt blinker polsat
ohren und tümmler gleiter und tripoli
es entsteht eine eigene lebendige welt
fast wie unsere es gibt sogar
verschiedene spezies die stoffwechsel
haben sich fortpflanzen können und sich
weiterentwickeln und all das entsteht
nur durch vier simple regeln was das
spiel des lebens und zeigt ist dass
komplexität aus den einfachsten dingen
entstehen kann und vielen von uns ist
das im alltag glaube ich nicht bewusst
aber jetzt kommt die frage ist das leben
stirbt der gleiter mit seinen fünf
pixeln wenn er von einem strudel
verschluckt wird natürlich nicht wäre
jetzt die antwort von geistig gesunden
und zurechnungsfähigen menschen
aber lasst uns mal für einen moment
verrückt sein und sehen wohin uns das
führt was ist wenn zellen im spiel des
lebens leben würden
was wäre wenn sie denken könnten gefühle
hätten und sterben würden
und wie groß muss das spielbrett dafür
sein schaut man sich aktuelle spiele
engines an die täuschend echt aussehen
und kaum noch von filmen aus der kamera
zu unterscheiden sind mit charakteren
die eine künstliche intelligenz haben
und mit dem spieler auf eine art
interagieren können wie es die
programmierer nicht direkt beabsichtigt
haben dann fällt es nicht schwer sich
vorzustellen dass leben in einem
computer simuliert werden kann
ich denke mal wir alle halten uns für
recht lebendig aber unser gehirn besteht
trotzdem nur aus einzelnen molekülen die
für sich genommen tote materie sind sie
folgen nur den gesetzen des universums
genauso wie die zellen vom spiel des
lebens den vier regeln folgen
was unterscheidet uns also von diesen
digitalen zellen auf einer festplatte
entweder sind sie lebendig oder wir sind
tot
aber das ist nur die spitze des eisbergs
wenn wir den gedanken weiter führen
stellt sich mir eine frage eine
existenzielle frage woher wissen wir
dass wir nicht in einer
computersimulation leben
dass wir nicht irgendwo auf einer
festplatte laufen und irgendjemand bald
den ausschalter
die idee wurde schon von unzähligen
filmen und büchern aufgegriffen es ist
science fiction zumindest für die
meisten nicht aber für ihren mast
gründer von firmen wie tesla motors und
space ex der vor kurzem genau diesen
gedanken auf einem panel diskutiert hat
die argumentation ist folgende da wir
aktuell einen stetigen fortschritt im
bereich von simulationen und
computerspielen beobachten können können
wir davon ausgehen dass simulationen
irgendwann ununterscheidbar von der
echten welt sein werden
wir haben heute schon täuschend echt
aussehende grafik engines virtual
reality headsets und die ersten
rudimentären computer zu gehirn
verbindungen die uns die optimale
täuschung erlauben würden
ob das heute oder in 10.000 jahren
passiert ist eigentlich egal denn im
vergleich zum zeitalter des universums
ist dass fast nichts wenn wir diesen
punkt erreichen wenn wir es schaffen
simulationen lebensecht zu machen
dann wissen wir auch dass andere
intelligente lebensformen ihn erreichen
können bzw das schon getan haben da es
extrem unwahrscheinlich ist dass wir die
erste intelligente lebensform im
universum sind
und sobald sie diesen punkt erreicht
haben werden sie diese simulationen
natürlich auch benutzen um mehr über das
universum zu erfahren um soziale
experimente durchzuführen oder einfach
nur zum zocken wer weiß so eine
gesellschaft hätte millionen und
abermillionen dieser simulationen am
laufen
die für lebewesen in dieser simulation
ununterscheidbar von der realität sind
bzw
für diese lebewesen ist die simulation
sogar die realität
und jetzt kommt der killer unsere chance
dass wir in der echten welt leben in der
basis realität und nicht in einer
simulation ist eins zu der anzahl der
simulationen die diese gesellschaft am
laufen hat also 1 2x millionen oder
milliarden
es ist viel wahrscheinlicher dass wir
teil einer simulation der ersten
intelligenten lebensformen sind als dass
wir in der basis realität des universums
sind
das ist ihre maske argument und bis
jetzt konnte ihn keiner widerlegen wie
auch man kann nie beweisen dass man
nicht in einer simulation lebt selbst
wenn wir unserer simulation entkommen
woher wissen wir dass unsere erschaffer
nicht auch schon ihr ganzes leben lang
simuliert wurden dass unsere gehirne und
gedanken und gefühle nur ladungen auf
einer festplatte sind dass komplexität
wie in computerspielen nur dann
existiert wenn sie berechnet werden muss
hierhin gucken wir können es nie wissen
ein letzter gedanke selbst wenn wir in
der basis realität sind wenn wir in der
echten welt sind und nicht in der
simulation dann kann es gut sein dass
wir uns bald freiwillig in eine
simulation begeben
wieso sollten wir in ein paar tausend
jahren wenn wir fortschrittliche technik
haben und unser universum in den meisten
belangen verstehen weiter nach außen
gehen
wieso sollten wir tausende planeten
erobern und besiedeln kann es nicht auch
sein dass wir nach innen gehen und uns
unsere eigene matrix schaffen in einer
lebensechten simulation in einem traum
lebt es sich doch viel schöner als in
dieser welt hier könnten wir alles
machen was wir wollen wir können die
welt die gesetze der physik und alles so
anpassen wie es uns gefällt und ein
perfektes leben leben und dank schneller
prozessoren könnte sich dieses leben
auch viel länger anfühlen als ein
normales menschenleben
das ist alles super philosophisch und
klingt wahrscheinlich so als wäre ich
verrückt geworden es ist im endeffekt
nur interessant darüber nachzudenken
denn am ende des tages ändert sich
nichts an unserer situation
oder daran wie wir unser leben leben wir
werden weiter zur schule oder zur arbeit
gehen unsere freunde treffen und
irgendwann den gedanken aus unserem kopf
sperren
dass das alles hier vielleicht nicht
echt ist das alles was wir kennen
nur eine simulation ist bei mir
explodiert jedes mal wieder der kopf
wenn ich darüber nachdenke aber es kommt
alles runter zum spiel des lebens wie
ich finde
wenn wir akzeptieren das leben in einer
simulation auch wirklich leben ist und
sich für diese wesen so anfühlt dann
folge hat sich alles andere daraus
deswegen habe ich euch zum schluss noch
ein kleines rätsel mitgebracht das hier
ist das ausgangs muster wie sieht das
muster nach drei runden aus a b c oder d
schaut euch nochmal die vier regeln vom
spiel des lebens an und schreibt auch
antwort in die kommentare unter das
video das ergebnis gibt es am sonntag
auf der facebook-seite von planet schule
und bei mir auf facebook twitter oder
instagram viel erfolg übrigens mal dass
hier jetzt schon das letzte der zehn
videos die ich in kooperation mit dem
wdr und der redaktion von planet schule
gemacht haben ich möchte mich noch mal
ganz herzlich bei der redaktion dafür
bedanken dass sie mir komplette freiheit
über die themen gegeben hat und ich die
videos so machen konnte wie sonst auch
oder die zuschauer wir sehen uns wie
immer nächsten donnerstag bis dann euer
fabrik